Well, good morning again, church, it's great to see you.
Uh, if you're new to our church, we're glad you are here.
We would love to meet you.
Uh, there's a couple ways to be able to do that.
You can just come say hello.
We are happy to do that always, of course.
But there's also new here area out there.
If you wanna go introduce yourself out there,
that'd be great as well.
Uh, we are this morning continuing in our new series called
Rail Realigned.
This series, we're walking
through Romans chapter 12 together,
where we're being challenged with
what a transformed life in Christ
actually looks like as we get into it.
Today, though, most of you know, I'm a sports guy,
like every one of 'em, it doesn't matter.
I'll watch curling.
Uh, it's just that football is probably my favorite.
Uh, it's something that has been part of what I do, uh,
in my life, of course, but mostly it's
because I see it as the ultimate team game, uh,
the ultimate team game.
And it's hard for one player to dominate.
You don't win alone in any way,
and you can't hide any weak links.
Everyone must play their part
or the first picture happens, right?
And I, I appreciate, uh, Brandon probably appreciates
that one of the Steelers, right?
But, uh, everyone must play their part.
Everyone must defer to one another.
You can't be just selfish in it.
Well, it's similar to what we're gonna study today
as we look at God's word.
This chapter teaches us about serving one another.
And we'll see how critical it is that everyone
does their part within the body of Christ.
Plus how we must be humble in order to maintain the unity
of the Spirit in the bond of peace,
as Ephesians four puts it.
And so if you're not already there, turn with me
to Romans chapter 12.
Again, we're in this for the, the long haul.
So bookmark Romans chapter 12.
Today we're gonna be in verses three through eight.
It's all about serving as you're turning it.
Remember that this whole chapter,
and really the rest of the book hinges on the first two
verses, Romans chapter 12, verses one and two.
That's a transitional section from chapters one through 11
where he highlights the theology, uh, of God's nature,
our predicament and our salvation.
Therefore, this is how we live it out.
And what he does remember in chapters one through 11,
I said this last week, is that he holds up Christ
as the perfect standard, as the plumb Bob
that we have seen in the bumper video.
But then also every week we're gonna have it up here
that this is the, the perfect vertical.
When we see Jesus, we see him as the standard,
what perfect vertical actually is.
Now we all fall short of that, of course.
So we need the grace of God in that.
But we're also to be realigned back to
that standard every day.
That's what Romans 12 shows us, is this is
what a realigned kind of life looks like.
So we need his grace, we need his mercy,
and we need his transformation in our lives.
And Romans 12 paints that picture for us.
It reminds us of God's mercies.
It reminds us, uh, to offer ourselves
as a living sacrifice to God.
And then we are to serve as a result of that.
That's the first thing He says,
after offering yourself not being conformed to the world,
the first thing he talks about is
serving one another within the church.
It's that important. Now again,
we've got a perfect standard.
So our model is Jesus,
Who in Mark 10 45, it says, came not to be served,
but to serve and to give his life as a ransom for many,
the king of the universe, the one worthy of being served.
He came not to be served but to serve.
So that's our standard.
That's what we're realigning back
to every single day of our lives.
And so look now at Romans chapter 12,
verses three through eight.
This is a transformed life of serving others.
Watch this For, by the grace given
to me, I say to everyone among you not to think
of himself more highly than he ought to think.
But to think with sober judgment, each according
to the measure of faith that God has assigned for,
as in one body, we have many members,
and the members do not all have the same function.
So we though many are one body in Christ
and individually members, one of another, having gifts
that differ according to the grace given to us.
Let us use them if prophecy in proportion to our faith,
if service in our serving, the one
who teaches in his teaching, the one
who exhorts in his exhortation, the one
who contributes in generosity, the one who leads with zeal,
the one who does acts of mercy with cheerfulness.
So God, this is your word and we come to it humbly,
and we want you to speak through it and change us today.
Make us more like Christ
and his service of us,
that we can serve one another like that.
But we know Holy Spirit, you've gotta change our hearts.
You've gotta make us unselfish kind of people
where we are prone to be so selfish.
So lead us, teach us today from this, that we be doers
of the word, not merely hearers, only
for your glory, for our good. In Jesus' name,
Amen.
So notice what we learned about this transformed life.
This life realigned to the perfect life of Christ.
First we learned that serving
that kinda life serving is founded on humility.
That's the first part of this. It's founded on humility.
This transformed life. We must found it on humility.
That was verse three, very clearly by the grace given to me,
I say to everyone among you, not to think
of himself more highly than he ought to think.
But to think with sober judgment, according to the measure
of faith, God is assigned.
Okay? So we've got to think differently.
So where does that start?
Well, first of all, we have
to think about seeing God rightly.
If we're gonna be humble and think about ourselves rightly,
we've gotta see God rightly first it all starts with him,
or top down theology, not bottom up theology.
This is what we are starting with is him.
And remember what Romans one through 11 taught.
It's that God is holy. God is a God of justice.
God is a God of wrath towards sin.
God is a God who's sovereign overall.
And in light of that, he is also merciful and gracious.
He's slow to anger. He's abounding
and steadfast love and faithfulness.
This is our God all through Christ.
That's how he shows up here in the world.
It's how we know him. So we see him
rightly, that's who he is.
And as we see God rightly, that leads us
to see ourselves rightly in light of who he is
when we see God rightly, you truly see yourself,
God is God, you're not.
And so you discover then the most important thing you
and I can live for in our lives is not ourselves.
If he is God and we're not,
we discover we should live for him.
That's the most important thing to live for.
And that's then what leads you to think of yourself, not
as highly as you often do to link.
Think of yourself, not more highly than you ought to think.
Now, some people take that too far. Are you valuable?
Absolutely you are. The point is,
you're just not more valuable than everyone else.
So what Philippians two says a lot,
we'll get to that in a moment.
But, but instead of thinking I'm more important than
everyone else, it says think with sober judgment.
A a phrase that means sensible.
That you're clearheaded, you're seeing things accurately.
There's no delusion, there's no deception.
There's no lying about your character to try
to put some reputation.
You're not just putting the,
the pure Instagram photos on there.
You're, you're putting everything out there.
It's, it's no delusion.
You are just humbly telling the truth about who you are
and who those people are,
which leads you, again, to what I said about Philippians
says this in Philippians two, verse three,
do nothing from selfish ambition or conceit,
but in humility,
count others more significant than yourselves.
The way of the world, the way of our flesh is
that I'm most important, I'm most significant.
This says, in Christ,
you count others more significant than you.
That's humility, right?
If you and I are going
to serve one another in the way God has designed us
to serve one another, we've got to lay aside.
Pretentiousness, got to lay aside selfishness.
We've gotta lay aside this desire
to build our own reputation.
We have to lay all that, count it as nothing, die
to ourselves and humble ourselves like Jesus did when he
washed his disciples feet.
You know why that was such a big deal?
Because that was an act reserved for the lowest
of the servants in the household.
And Jesus, the one they saw,
this is the Messiah, this is the king.
He did it. And that's the context.
He said, I didn't come to be served. I came to serve.
Do this just like I'm doing it for you.
Do this for one another. Serve one another like this.
And so we've got to be humble.
We have to start with humility.
If we see ourselves too highly,
we're not gonna serve others.
But there's a second point here in Romans 12
that this lifestyle, this realigned lifestyle
of serving is supported by unity.
It's founded on humility. We start there, see God, right?
See ourselves, right then it's also supported by unity.
Look again at verses four through six here,
for as in one body, we have many members.
And the members do not all have the same function.
He's looking at our physical bodies there.
So we though many are one body in Christ
and individually members, one of another, having gifts
that differ according to the grace given to us.
Let us use them.
Now, if you read the Bible for any length of time,
you see this is the most common illustration it gives
for the church.
This idea of the body, it helps us understand the nature
of what this thing is we call the church.
And so here's what it teaches us.
It teaches us that the body parts,
we are all different, right?
So as the body parts are all different,
that's the same way it works in your physical body
and it works that way in the church.
All the body parts are different.
There are many unique members.
We all have different gifts from God.
And you can see that just by turning around
and looking around this room, right?
We are all very, very different with our backgrounds,
with diverse sin, struggles that we all may have.
The varying shapes and sizes, we won't get into that at all.
Like diff different financial situations of life.
There's all kinds of things
that we have uniquely talented abilities, passions,
we're all over the place where you were born,
where you were coming from, all of that very different.
And life would be really boring if we were all
the same, wouldn't it?
This is God's design for us to be
so different from one another.
It's intentional because it uniquely reveals his glory.
That if God can create such diverse people
and then bring them together in unity, that is only by God.
And it's the same way with our physical bodies.
Kids just, just look at your hand, kids, right?
Hold your hand up. Look at that. It's different than your
nose, isn't it?
Right? Like it's, it's very different.
Each body part has a different purpose and function.
They're not the same. But I have two hands.
Yeah, but you have two different hands. I have two. Okay.
No, but just you, you can think through it.
They are still different.
The church has many members. We are all different.
Not all have the same function.
So the principle, he,
the Bible teaches us about the nature of the church.
Yet remember what Romans 12 said.
If you notice that while we are different,
we are all still one.
We are different yet still
one a couple times.
Verse four says, there is one body, verse five,
though many, we are one body in Christ.
Verse Corinthians 1227, we are the body of Christ.
Now, all that language, it smells like unity, doesn't it?
I guess just one. There's one, there's one. Think about it.
The parts of your physical body are not to compete
with one another.
We're not to think that this part
of the body is more valuable than that part of the body.
Each part of the body is to work towards the same goal
that the head dreams up the brain functions thinking,
this is what I want to do.
And so the rest of the body says, all right,
we're gonna do everything we can to get us there.
If one part of the body is working in one direction,
another part of the body is working a totally different
direction, or if one part
of the body is being neglected than the body will not
function as it was intended to function.
And we completely get this.
We understand this just inherently, physically, we get it.
We all have to work towards one purpose.
Not only are we one, this passage also taught that we are
dependent on one another.
It's not just that we're one together,
we're unified and we're one body.
It's that we are actually dependent on one another.
That's what verse five says.
We are individually members, one of another.
We're not just members of the body.
We're members one of another. We're interconnected.
We're not just like a, a random collection pile
of body parts all thrown together, that we just happen
to be in the same vicinity.
We are actually interconnected, interdependent
body of members.
I love how one Corinthians puts this chapter 12,
verses 21 through 26 says, the eye cannot say to the hand,
I have no need of you, nor again, the head to the feet.
I have no need of you. On the contrary, the parts
of the body that seem to be weaker, are indispensable.
And on those parts of the body, we think less honorable.
We bestow the greater honor.
And our unpresentable parts are treated
with greater modesty,
which are more presentable parts do not require.
But listen, God has so composed the body,
he designed the body such
that giving greater honor to the part that lacked it,
that there may be no division in the body,
but that the members may have the same care for one another.
If one member suffers, all suffer together.
If one member is honored, all rejoice together.
So again, let me summarize what this is teaching us.
For us to be all that God created us to be,
for the body of Christ to function as God intended it
to function, then I need you.
You need me. You need each other. We need all of us.
No one can sit on the sidelines.
No one can be neglected or excluded.
If that happens, then we will not fulfill the glorious
purpose for which God created the church, the body.
But just think, then imagine, as we do all, participate,
as we do all engage and serve
and realign our lives with the perfect vertical of Christ
and the way he served us.
And we can serve each other like that.
As we do that, watch out.
Be amazed at what God will do with that.
Maybe not convinced yet.
So lemme give you a further illustration to help even more.
I wanna invite Mark and Randy to come on up
and help me with this one.
These are two faithful servants of the Lord.
They play the piano all the time. They're incredible.
What we wanna do is give you a musical example of
what I have just talked about for a while already.
And so here's what we're gonna do, mark, uh,
why don't you just start by playing a, a simple melody,
just one hand, one part being played with this,
okay?
It's nice. Like we can enjoy that. We understand.
We, we know that song. We we've heard that before, right?
We'll just add another part to that, one more part added
to it that's complimentary to the first part.
Okay? It's beautiful, beautiful.
Notice how the two parts are different.
But as his two parts fulfill their roles in the same song,
what you see is a beautiful more full picture.
Well, Randy, why don't you add two more parts to this
and just see what this wonderful song can sound like,
Like Four different parts working together,
dependent on each other for it all to work
and to be beautiful.
Okay, so now let's think though
how it could go a different way.
So Randy, why don't you start, let,
let's flip the, the roll here a little bit.
Randy, why don't you start with just that one hand,
one line, one part.
Just start with that melody again.
Okay? Now add your, your second part.
Okay, now, mark, why don't you add two more parts
like Randy did before.
Beautiful. But what if Mark
insisted on his own way and said, you know what?
I wanna play it at a faster tempo
than what Randy's playing it.
Same song, but faster tempo.
Okay, that, that, that doesn't work, right?
That's just a nutty mess. It sounds terrible.
Okay, so let's get back to, uh, the unity again.
All right, start, start again.
Let's see how we're doing that.
Okay, well, what if this time Randy decided on his own way
and he wanted to play this song at, at, at a different key.
Okay. Uh,
same song, same tempo.
Okay, alright, that's enough. Okay. Alright.
Uh, ouch. Right?
But church, listen, isn't that what happens in churches
so often is that people choose
to play different songs, different tempos, different keys,
and it just sounds like that.
Or they, they, they insist on their own way
or they, they want to use their gifts for themselves, not
for others, but like,
just think, wouldn't we much rather
have every part playing the same song in the the same tempo
on the same key?
Can't, can't we long for that?
And just again, what it sounds like, I,
Oh man, okay.
Can we say thank you to Mark and Randy for that?
Oh, oh man.
And did you see how much fun they were having too
as they were playing their parts
and just how hard it was, first of all, for them
to play it wrong first that was amazing.
But then how much fun it is to play it correctly
and to see, to see
the parts fit together like it does.
It's an amazing picture.
See, church, we all have different parts to play,
but we have one body with one song,
the Song of Christ, and we are all
dependent on one another.
See, a musician cannot insist on his own way
or it's gonna go really badly,
but it goes really well.
And it's so much fun when every part is playing their
part for the same song.
Same tempo, same key.
We're heading in the right direction together.
That's why the final aspect of
what we learn here about serving is
that it is oriented toward others.
It's not about me, it's not about you. It's not selfish.
It is oriented toward others.
That's why he lists out in verses six through eight,
these gifts, watch this, he said, having gifts
that differ according to the grace given to us.
Let us use them if prophecy
and proportion to our faith if service in our serving,
the one who teaches in his teaching, the one
who exhorts in his exhortation, the one
who contributes in generosity, the one who leads with zeal,
the one who does acts of mercy with cheerfulness.
So he's talking about gifts.
Now, you might not be aware of what these are.
These are called spiritual gifts.
These are supernatural abilities from God, empowered by God
and his spirit in you to use for the church.
And this list here that he lists is not exhaustive
because there's other lists at other times,
the New Testament that are mentioned elsewhere.
Things like evangelism or discernment or languages.
There's all kinds of other things
that we could list out in that.
And so he does these lists and we can collate those
and put 'em all together as one large list.
But here's the thing about those gifts, just
because you may only have one
or two of those gifts,
it does not exclude you from practicing those gifts when
they're commanded of you in other ways.
Like evangelism is not my gift.
I can't walk up to somebody and just have a conversation.
It's hard for me. It's not supernaturally empowered by me,
but I'm still called to share the gospel, right?
So it's not gift, but it's a command.
Mercy, same thing that's not natural to you.
You still called to show mercy, it just might not come
as easily if you don't have the gift, that's okay.
It's commanded.
But if you have that gift, it is
flourishing in you and through you.
That's what spiritual gifts are.
That's what he's talking about here.
So here's the question, then it arises from this.
How do you know what your gift or gifts is?
How do you know? Like how, how, how would you find this out?
Do you know? Like,
do you know what God has given you?
Do you know how you are gifted by the Lord
to serve his body as a member?
The reality is sadly, many Christians don't know
and we kind of assume or we kind of have some sense, but,
but we don't know.
But just think again, how much more effective you would be
if you did know, like, this is my lane,
this is what I'm supposed to do.
Like how much of a joy would it be for you to know
and find it and then run in your lane?
Mine teaching leading administration,
those are my top three gifts.
And so when I'm doing this, when I'm leading,
when I'm adminis like kind of detail focused, like I see
and sense God's blessing and God's pleasure on it,
because that's my lane over here.
These other things, those aren't my
lane, but that's one of yours.
That's yours. That's yours. That, that's, that's
where you're supposed to be your part of the body.
This is my part of the body and God is blessing it.
Okay? So if you don't know, how do you find out?
Well, here's one of the best ways.
Ask the people who know you the best.
Just ask the people that are in your life
that are watching you and knowing you and,
and discovering things with you.
Like ask them, what is my spiritual gift?
What do you think it is? And if you ask enough people,
it might start to align around a few things.
You're like, oh, okay, that, that may be it.
But here's another tool. We've got a quick online
assessment that helps.
It's not perfect, but at least might help you.
And so I sent a link in my email last week.
I'll send it again this upcoming week.
There's also, if you're using the notes,
the sermon notes on the app,
there's a a link button embedded into the app.
You could take it from there.
There's also a QR code on your physical notes.
If you have the paper copy,
you can go home and do that today.
And so let me just encourage you
to take a few minutes this afternoon.
You get home, say, God, I'm gonna lay in my life.
I'm gonna turn the TV off, turn my phone off.
I'm gonna lay my life before you as a living sacrifice
and say, okay, God, show me how you've gifted me.
I want to know and just be honest and
and work through something like this assessment
and just say, God, I want to know.
Because here's the thing, God would not include these lists
of gifts in His word
if he didn't intend for us to know them
and use them what he's given us.
He wouldn't name them if he didn't say to
somebody, you've got that gift.
Use it. We need
to find our gifts and use them.
Which leads to the second question then
that comes from this passage.
Once you discover your gift, how then can you use
that gift for others?
How can you use the gift
that God gave you for others?
Every spiritual gift is for the benefit of others.
It's not for you.
Like a tree does not produce fruit for itself.
It doesn't produce apples and then cannibalize those apples
and gorge itself on its own fruit.
That's not the point.
The point of a fruit tree is so that it would produce fruit
for others good, that it would produce other trees
to nourish and support
and care for others within the body of Christ.
That's why he gave us gifts.
See, he didn't give me the gift of teaching for me
to build some platform for myself.
He gave me the gift of teaching so that I can benefit you.
The body of Christ serve the body in that unique small way
to serve the church and say, here's what I want to do.
God said through you for the benefit of the church.
Your gift of giving is to benefit others.
It's not to promote yourself
or to make a name for yourself of how much you gave.
Your gift of giving is to serve others
with the resources God gave you
And so on and so forth.
You can see all these gifts could be used for ourselves,
but instead they're to be used for others.
One Peter four 10 reminds us that
as each has received a gift, use it
to serve one another as good stewards
of God's varied grace.
So unique, different.
Each one of you has a different gift
and passion of how to use that.
It's beautiful, it's varied,
but we ought to be good stewards of it.
And again, I said it
before, it's essential that every part
is utilizing their unique gift following our head.
I'm not the head, the elders aren't the head.
Jesus is the head of the church.
So we're following our head.
Jesus Christ, he's leading us in direction.
He's coming up with the ideas and we are to follow him.
If we don't each use our gift, then our growth
as a church will be stunted.
Listen to this. Ephesians four
says it so well.
And God gave the apostles, prophets, evangelist shepherds
and teachers to equip the saints, the church for the work
of ministry, for building up the body of Christ
Until we all attain to the unity of the faith
and the knowledge of the Son of God to mature manhood
to the measure, the stature of the fullness of Christ, so
that we may no longer be children tossed to
and fro by the waves carried about by every wind
of doctrine, by human cunning, by craftiness
and deceitful schemes by the way of the world.
Basically rather speaking the truth in love, we are
to grow up in every way into him.
Who is the head into Christ?
From whom the whole body joined
and held together by every joint
with which is equipped When each part check this out,
when each part is working properly,
makes the body grow so that it builds itself up in love.
When each part is working properly, the body grows.
When each part is working properly,
when each part is using the gift God gave it.
We are all built up in love. We all grow in maturity.
We are all strengthened against the attacks of the enemy.
Again, interdependent members of the body.
The church then suffers.
If anyone does not fulfill his or her God-given role.
Each member is vital to the body of Christ functioning as he
designed it to function.
So what's your gift? How has he blessed you?
Ask people who know you best, like just ask.
Try to get some input on that. Take the assessment later.
Just just how has he gifted you?
How has he gifted you for the body?
But then again, don't stop there.
Ask God, how do you want me to use this for the benefit
of others to serve the church?
How do you want me to be doing that?
Again, we wanna help you. Our call in Ephesians four is
to equip the saints for the work of the ministry.
So we wanna help you get there.
And so on the notes on the app, in the email,
there's another button, there's a second QR code,
there's a second link that can help you fill out all of
that information so
that you can better apply the gift
God's given you in this church.
You're like, okay, now I know what my gift is.
I don't know what to do with that.
I don't know how to serve.
We wanna help you there. So you've got two QR codes,
two links, all of that to specifically help you how to serve
and fulfill this realignment back
to the service Christ gave.
But again, don't forget this, above all else,
this all starts by seeing God rightly first,
by then seeing ourselves rightly in light of that,
by understanding the nature of the body of Christ,
the church, and giving ourselves wholeheartedly to him,
you serve the Lord Christ.
You're not serving me, you're not serving the church,
you're serving Jesus.
And so we do that with all our hearts.
We do that with all our effort.
This is walking in the newness of life
that Romans six described, that we are dead to sin,
we're alive to God,
and we are called to live
that truth out even today, not just someday.
And so again, as you think about this, serving
may be scary at first.